it's always going to be something you've
only been married once so what's
tomorrow yeah yeah yeah and only will be
married once it's only going to happen
so when all this starts first happening
right yeah does Mariah call you be like
what the [__] are you doing bro oh not
really we have that type of like type of
conversation but she's a little bit more
understanding she's got to be like I see
you out there Making Waves like she kind
of comes from it more from that
perspective but that there was no I
think only sometimes maybe when things
in the media get misconstrued or people
make up stuff like you got to clear it
up yeah we talk every day so I'm like yo
like it was some wild [__] of like
saying that we were having like a
custody battle or something I saw that
yeah and it was like I was like we just
was at dinner yesterday you ain't tell
me you know but it's like once we kind
of do away with all the rumors because
people do like to start rumors and
operating at low frequency but we all we
all be on the same phase do you still
have the tattoo would you cover it up I
added to it shall we say cat
it's my whole that was my only tattoo at
one time now I remember Daddy I remember
yeah I was like this this guy's outside
yeah yeah yeah he got the home it was
Mariah Carey damn right I can't buy or
nothing that she can't buy it Ryan Carey
was my as a small child she was like my
first crush yeah so when I saw I was
like shout out to Nick man it was Brian
JLo yeah and actually my boy ended up
being with JLo Casper Smart see look at
his young tycoons out here in these
streets getting it together man
um how I want to talk about because I
don't feel like you get enough credit in
terms of your ear for Talent on the
music side uh a girl like keilani
somebody who was signed with you
initially her was signed when she was
11. yeah to you to incredible yeah
um you have like a now she went in
Oscars and Grammys and stuff shouts out
the young Gabby out there yeah how like
for you like
why do you think you'll get enough
credit man when it comes to the music
[__] because I feel like I think I feel
like people obviously think listen
you've put out some dope records but I
also feel like people don't really take
you serious as an as an artist never
tried to push it well also because I
feel like we just see you as doing so
many other things and like I came up in
a time where you couldn't do more than
one thing right so I had to pick and
choose so I chose you know you know
comedy and yeah Gigolo movies and [__]
but so you couldn't do both when I was
young right but what's dope is that I I
was a DJ and a producer like all through
high school so I didn't really I never
wanted to be in front of the camera so
throughout my career I've written and
produced records that
there I got platinum records all day
long but it's just like I never was like
this is me looking and paying attention
to me even when it came to the Artistry
stuff I never was really on that so what
I've done now just because obviously the
spotlight is hot I I created a new show
for BT uh called future Superstars and
it's a tour as well so I saw you just
were on tour with uh Simba 24K so yeah
so the fact that now the television show
will show that Journey they would show
you know me as a music man and show me
in the space of talent Discovery or show
me me as a producer and all of that type
of stuff so I'm excited about that that
wave of my career because I had it has I
I haven't talked about it it has been
the afterthought a lot of times even
though I've been doing you know I make
all the music on wild and out you know
what I mean like I I it's a I'm a
musician's musician so that's where like
the fact that you know I could play
drums piano guitar all of that stuff
I've never really been like oh look how
well I rhymed these words together shout
out to everybody who does that but that
was never like my main focus because I
was more about creating movements and
creating opportunities so uh I'm glad
now that I get the opportunity to kind
of take that side of my career seriously
when you have like someone like her you
sign her as a kid sign her as a kid
um or Kaylani was she signed you before
she was 18 yeah yeah they were she was
right before she finished high school
what was the name of the group that went
on tour with tech nine uh psych ward
druggies a kid passed away who was in
there yeah Ryan Bowers rest his soul man
that was my man
but do you like like you let them out of
their deals did the deals run their
course I'm not even one of them dudes
like I'm like everybody else around me
wants me to be one of those dudes like
take the credit sign on me you put your
logo on it I'm like look give me the
credit when you want to give me the
credit right other than that it's cool
like I'm a handshake type of person I
don't want nothing from you uh except to
see you win so that's a rare thing in
this game but it's like I always tell
artists that I rock with look I'm Gonna
Be Rich whether you make it or not like
so I don't need like those ideas is like
I don't need anything from you like I'm
just gonna help you out so all I want to
do let me help you I'll give you advice
and see how you run but you know
obviously a lot of people think that you
know I should I should be taking
percentages and doing all of that so
usually I only ask for you know ass back
for the money that I put in if you're if
you're stable enough to do that but I
don't even have I mean you know these
major labels still owe me owe me checks
for you know the artist that I kindly
just gave them so but I just I did that
because I wanted to see those artists
win and didn't want them to get into a
deal in debt so I can always step away
but you know those those big record
execs you know you know who you owe
they owe you some money absolutely for
if they look up the paperwork but I mean
I'm I'm good with all those people just
based off of the but I definitely like I
said I never wanted anything from them
right like I always wanted them to
succeed and even their Arrangements that
we made with uh various management and
various uh record labels I was like yo
I'll be I'll step back now that I know
they're in good hands you know I'm off
to the next thing because I really don't
want anything from anybody but when
those major systems who make hundreds of
millions of dollars off of these artists
like yeah here let me get my investment
back yeah yeah at least give me the
money that I've spent to to bring them
to you so you know but again I ain't
that that small paper I ain't really
counting was there anyone who uh you
almost signed that it got right to the
finish line but for whatever reason yeah
a couple people like Becky G I remember
Becky G early on you know uh she was she
was like a little 14 year old girl
rapping yeah uh
so many people uh
I mean because I used to run uh teen
Island at Def Jam LA Reid put me in
charge of all of the Teen acts and you
know obviously the the it was it was a
cool roster it was a group I created
called the school girls this artist
named Aaron Fresh who was super dope uh
and we had a arsenal of artists and I
was making I was putting them all in
Gabby was a part of that as well we put
them all in these Nickelodeon movies uh
that we were making in the first the the
star at the time the one that obviously
the the biggest act on teen Island he
just was bubbling up the internet was
this young kid named Justin Bieber
the rest is history really the whole
teen Island budget just folded and went
into beaver's career and it's the Justin
Bieber that we know to this day so was
that prior to him linking with Usher it
was during the same time same time same
time that was like it was like I said
Tina he had he got the deal in the
building but as you you know you know
they upstreamed him quick yeah yeah so
like uh I think I think the the
Nickelodeon movie that we put on was
Justin's first thing ever on television
so uh in the first movie and stuff that
he had ever did because before then he
was just this dope little kid from
YouTube that they were about to put out
a record and all that and so I was like
yo he about to go and then he he went oh
he went oh